dr. strange is finally here to blow our
minds with another mystical side of the
Marvel Universe we're introduced to a
host of new characters that inhabit the
hidden world of sorcerers on infinite
dimensions but if all these new faces
have you confused don't worry we're here
to help sort it out here's a look at
characters and Doctor Strange we mean
more than you realized
Baron Mordo considering his doctor
strangers closest ally and the Ancient
Ones top pupil Karl Mordor sudden he'll
turn in the post-credits II might have
come as a surprise to some people but
it's all part of Marvel's master plan
see in the comics Mordo is also
strangest archenemy in fact the plus of
the film is based on a famous storyline
that saw more dough rather than
cassellius betray the ancient one in an
attempt to curry favor with Dormammu in
a way everything that happens in this
movie is just setting the stage for more
doze villainy in future films one as the
librarian akarma tosh one is kind of a
strict guy seemingly incapable of
laughter but secretly harboring a love
of beyonce but you can expect to see a
lot more of him in future films in the
comics one gets Doctor Strange is
steadfast partner and best friend we
look forward to seeing Wong and Stevens
friendship blossom in future films and
we can't wait to see one open up more
cans of butt-kicking action with the
Karma Tosh style of martial arts
nicodemus West while he wasn't given
much screen time strangers colleague and
rival dr. Nika Dimas West is a little
more interesting than he seems well I
guess I'll just have to stick with Nick
oh wait a minute you're not you guys
aren't what sleeping together sorry I
thought that was implicit in my discuss
an explicit actually in the comics as in
the film he operated on strangers hands
after his accident leaving them with
nerve damage but in the comics he also
later followed strange to Karma Tosh and
trained in the magic arts as well it
suggests that there may be more to his
appearance in the movie than we first
thought
Kristine Palmer a surgeon and a former
flame to Stephen strange Kristine Palmer
also has her own longer bizarre history
in the comics she appeared as one of the
main characters in the night nurse
comics which also inspired Rosario
Dawson's character in Marvel's line of
Netflix shows and later even had a row
Nightcrawler from the x-men it's fairly
certain we won't see rachel mcadams
appear as dr. Parma in any x-men films
but we look forward to seeing a return
in future dr. strange adventures cloak
of levitation in dr. strange the cloak
of levitation is an ancient magical
relic with a mind of its own choosing to
help strange by protecting him while he
was under attack from Dharma Musa lots
in the comics the cloak of levitation
was a gift from the ancient one and has
even held dr. strange save the universe
a time or two but while it's powerful it
just doesn't quite have the same
personality that it does in the movie
black shield Dormammu Dormammu
I've come to bargain those are words
you'll likely hear a lot from Doctor
Strange fans while strange might have
been successful in annoying the demon
lord of dark dimension into submission
he didn't actually kill him it's also
important to note that the bargain
strange made of Dormammu said that the
demon would have to leave Earth alone
but it didn't say anything about strange
leaving the Dark Dimension alone and
since Doctor Strange is one true love in
the comics clear is actually damar Moo's
nice and eventual successor as ruler of
the Dark Dimension it's a fair bet we'll
see Dormammu again and this time on his
terms
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and watch more videos like the one you
just saw and don't forget to check out
all this cool stuff we know you're loved
too